hey this is press to Walker two points
are picked at random uniformly from the
border of a square with side length
L what is the probability the distance D
between the points is larger than
l i saw this on Reddit askmath which
credited a post by V software on
LinkedIn and I also credit the user
impressive dig 6678 for posting it and
the solution from the user
555 pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this
[Music]
problem I will first demonstrate how you
can estimate the answer numerically and
then I will present an analytic solution
so let's get started with a
simulation the first thing we'll do is
we'll set up a coordinate system suppose
the lower left corner of the square has
coordinates of the origin 0 comma 0
without loss of generality suppose the
square has a side length equal to one
then the other vertices of the square
have coordinates of 1 comma 0 1A 1 and
0a
1 now we will pick two points at random
on the edges of this
Square knowing their coordinates we can
use the distance formula to calculate
the distance between the two points we
can then say for each trial is this
length greater than
one we can then do this for many many
trials in each trial we're picking two
random points and we're seeing if the
length is going to be greater than
one after we do 1,000 trials we get a
numerical estimate of
0.359
which is pretty close to the analytic
solution you can of course do more
trials but this is just to show how you
can get a pretty good answer just by
simulation so now let's solve the
problem
analytically to get started we'll ask
the question where could the first point
be it could be on the left side of the
square it could be on the bottom side of
the square it could be on the right side
of the square or it could be on the top
side of the square now we can take
advantage of a symmetry of the square
all four of these cases are equally
likely without loss of generality we can
suppose the first point is on the bottom
side of the square you can imagine after
the first point is picked we can rotate
the entire Square to force it to be on
the bottom side of the
square now where could the second point
be there are four equally likely cases
one case is that that the second point
is on the bottom side the same side of
the square in this case it's impossible
for the distance between the two points
to be greater than l so this probability
is
zero the second Point could also be on
the opposite side of the square in this
case the probability the distance
between the points is greater than L is
equal to one they are necessarily at
least a distance of L
apart now there are two remaining cases
one is that it could be on the adjacent
right side and the other is it could be
on the adjacent left side now by
symmetry each of these probabilities
will be equal to each other so we need
to figure out the probability that D is
greater than l in one of these cases so
let's suppose it's on the adjacent left
side we will now set up a coordinate
system let's suppose the first point is
X comma 0 and the second point is 0
comma y the square is L comma
L we will further consider the line
between these two points and look at the
midpoint of this line which will have
coordinates X over2 and Y over
2 because the points are chosen at
uniform X and Y are uniform on 0 comma L
that means the midpoint m is uniform on
0a l/2 by 0a L over2 so let's think
about what that means graphically
let's consider the extreme cases suppose
the second point is all the way at the
left top corner of the square and the
first point is all the way at the bottom
right corner this will be the maximum
values for the midpoint M of X over2 and
Y over2 this will be the corner of a
square with end points l/2 comma L
over2 now for any other way that we pick
the points we will be stuck somewhere
inside of this Square so the point m is
uniform between all of the points of
this
Square so we can now ask what is the
locus of points M for which the distance
between the two points has a length
exactly equal to l the side length of
the square let's work through some
examples so we can imagine the two
points are like this the distance
between them is exactly L and the
midpoint will be right here
if we slide this over the midpoint will
be here we can slide it over again and
we continue tracing out all of these
points so what shape does this resemble
we exactly get a quarter
circle now we can actually prove this so
let's take a look at our diagram here
now m is at X over2 comma y over2 so
this will split this diagram into two
congruent right triangles where one leg
is equal to X over 2 and the other leg
is equal to y/ 2 now the length of half
of this distance will be l/2 so each of
these hypotenuses is equal to
l/2 therefore we have the square of x/2
plus the square of Y /2 is equal to the
square of L
over2 this exactly describes the path of
this quarter
circle now where do we go from here take
a look at the region that's contained in
this quarter Circle if m is anywhere in
here the distance between the two points
will be less than l so the probability
that D is less than or equal to l is
equal to the area of the quarter Circle
divided by the area of this shaded
Square so the area of the quarter circle
is 1 over4 * pi multip the radius
squared the radius is equal to l over2
and the area of this square is equal to
the square of l/2
so this simplifies to be pi over
4 but remember we want the probability
that D is greater than l so that will be
the remaining area so the probability
that D is greater than L will be the
complement event so this works out to be
1 - piun over 4 so we're now ready to do
the final
calculation there are four equally
likely cases for the second point and we
figured out the last two cases each have
a probability that's equal to 1 1 - < 4
now each of these four cases is equally
likely so each has a probability of 1
over
4 so the final probability will be equal
to 1 over4 multipli by the sum of these
probabilities and this exactly works out
to be 3 over4 minus pi/ 8 which is
approximately equal to
357 and that's the answer thanks for
making us one of the best communities on
YouTube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve The World's
problems one video at a
time